هاجم رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو خطوه جنوب افريقيا امام محكمه
العدل الدوليه واتهامها تل ابيب بارتكاب
جرائم اباده جماعيه بحق الفلسطينيين وقال
نتنياهو ان بلاده متهمه باباده شعب في وقت
تحارب فيه اباده شعب متهما جنوب افريقيا
بالنفاق
الخم نحن نحارب المخربين والاكاذيب اليوم
راي مجددا عالما مقلوبا راسا على عقب دوله
اسرائيل متهمه باباده شعب في وقت تحارب
فيه اباده شعب حماس نفذت جرائم فظيعه ضد
الانسانيه لقد ذبحوا وحرقوا واغتصبوا
وقطعوا رؤوس اطفال ونساء ومسنين منظمه
ارهابيه نفذت اكبر الجرائم ضد اليهود منذ
المحرقه النازيه وثم من ياتي اليوم للدفاع
عنهم باسم المحرقه اي وقاحه هذه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو الاكثر اخلاقيه في العالم
الذي يفعل كل شيء كي يمنع المساس بغير
الضالعين هو من يتهم من قبل ممثل الوحوش
باباده شعب نفاق جنوب افريقيا
صارخ